well there is even more confusion
tonight about whether the eviction
moratorium has
ended or not the cdc just announced they
plan to extend it until october 3rd
however a previous supreme court ruling
indicated that only
congress could extend it past saturday's
deadline so president biden said he
hopes it'll
buy people time to apply for rental
assistance while it works its way
through the courts
in the meantime 9 000 people in clark
county are waiting
to find out if their applications for
rental help will be approved
a local business owner tells the i-team
it's not just tenants who are struggling
right now
he says landlords and property managers
are left to pick up the pieces literally
the i-team's vanessa murphy explains
while some tenants are facing an
eviction crisis the owner of a property
management company says some
landlords are facing a crisis of their
own
finding some properties left like this
after tenants are kicked out
you can see a window broken belongings
left behind
the place is just trashed what other
businesses vilified for trying to stay
in business
but yet property managers are owners are
derrick molinger owns vice realty which
he says manages about 650 units
throughout the las vegas valley
he tells the i-team this is a frequent
problem closet doors ripped off
properties destroyed
after tenants are locked out we don't
just file a piece of paper kick someone
out because we don't like them
if the eviction moratorium ends
mullinger estimates he'll soon be
locking out tenants in 20 units for
unpaid rent
something he says could have been
prevented if they applied for rental
assistance
they don't want it because they see us
as us against them
and it's really not that way we have a
symbiotic relationship i need tenants
tenants need me
while evictions are expected to increase
rent in southern nevada
is also going up i was calling to tell
him that i was going to pay it on friday
the i-team first contacted mullinger
after we met his
tenant tommy wesley monday he told the
i-team his rent was raised by
275 dollars which mullinger
confirms that's a really big jump how
can you justify that
same way the gas station justifies going
from 243 in january to 4.11 cents today
same way home depot charges 70 for a
sheet of plywood now
and it used to be in the teens same way
when i go to the grocery store prices
went up
he says in many cases he's willing to
work with tenants like wesley by giving
them another month
at the old rate but he also has
obligations to the landlords he
represents
they're trying to make a living some of
them count on this for their retirement
some of them
yes they have a bunch of units and this
is a business for them the majority of
people it's not that
mullinger says at the end of the day he
just wants the rent money whether it's
from the rental assistance
or directly from tenants vanessa murphy
8 news now thank you vanessa well clark
county reports that 9 000 applications
for rental assistance are pending
right now they are making it through
about 800 to a thousand a week
now if a tenant applies they cannot be
kicked out mullinger says he is
frustrated with how slow the process is
going
so we put a list of resources on our
website 8newsnow.com
it includes a link for rental assistance
and what tenants should do if they
receive
an eviction notice